i just wanted to finish off ask you a
question minds because we've been joined
by young pragnanda today who's had a few
very crazy days after that win against
you massive attention from media from
fans and you've experienced that
yourself of course do you have any tips
for a young player to stay grounded and
focused and and keep playing great chess
uh yeah i think it's it's exactly uh
exactly exactly that um give people the
the space to develop and
don't expect
you know
the
you know something very special every
time because um
that's that's not realistic i think um
he's shown a lot of promise over the
last
few tournaments both here and also in
in my concert he clearly has has a lot
to learn but he's on he's on the right
track and
the more
time and space he
he can be given to
um to develop at his face then
[Music]
than the better but he's um
um
he's obviously doing very well
all right thanks for that inside magnus
and we wish you best of luck in semis
tomorrow thanks for joining us thank you